MARTIN OMANDER: Hi, Dina.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Hi, Martin.
What's up?
MARTIN OMANDER: In
a previous episode,
you showed me your checklist
for reporting containerized web
apps to Cloud Run.
And by running them
serverlessly on Cloud Run,
I got autoscaling.
I only pay when my
code is running.
And I don't have to
do server maintenance.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
Actually, I believe
I showed you two checklists.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, right.
The first checklist
was for finding out
if my containerized app
can be ported to Cloud Run.
And it said that the
container should be stateless.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
That's right.
MARTIN OMANDER: And
then in the comments,
you were asked how to port
containerized web apps that
store and use sessions--
in other words, apps that
are stateful on the server.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: OK, well,
those containers can still
be ported to Cloud Run.
But it does require
a few more steps.
Let me show you how.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN OMANDER: All right, I
have this e-commerce web app
that keeps track of the
user's shopping cart contents
between requests.
And it does so with
server side sessions.
For example, if I reload
the page like this,
the session is still active,
so the shopping cart content
is still there.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
I see, yeah.
That does make the
container stateful.
Any time your application
reads and writes data locally,
for instance, to a database
or a key value store,
this means that your
application is stateful.
And that's just a way
of saying that you're
saving the state locally.
But let's focus on the
user sessions right now.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Yeah, why do we even
need to think about
statefulness, Dina?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
Well, OK, here's the deal.
If your server side code stores
user session data and memory,
it's easy to lose it.
MARTIN OMANDER: Why is that?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
Well, for instance,
your server may crash,
which wipes out its memory.
Also, if you're running your
app on a serverless platform,
like Cloud Run,
each user request
is sent to the next
available instance,
which may not be
the instance that
has the user session in memory.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, that
sounds like a huge problem.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
Yeah, exactly.
So try not to store sessions
in the server's memory.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK, but I've
got to store the session data
between requests somewhere.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Yes,
store it outside the server.
For instance, Redis
is an open source
distributed key value store.
And it is a great
alternative to saving locally
because it's fast
and it can still
be reached by your
application servers.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK, but my
app uses the Express framework
with the Express
session package.
And that package stores session
data in memory on the server.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
You're right.
It does by default.
But you can edit it.
You can add a Redis
connector to it.
Many frameworks, like Express,
Django, Flask, Laravel, Spring
Boot, Koa, Gin,
and Ruby on Rails,
can be configured to use
Redis for session storage.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
Let me go and read the
docs for Express session
and see if I can
connect it to Redis.
Let's meet back here
for a little bit?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
Sounds good.
I will grab a cup of tea.
MARTIN OMANDER: All
right, I'm back, Dina.
I added the Redis
connector to my app.
It requires the address
of a Redis server
and a port it listens to.
So my code now
reads those values
from environment variables.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Well done.
So let's set up
your Redis server.
Go to the Cloud Console,
open the hamburger menu,
and click Memory Store.
Memory Store is Google's
hosted solution for Redis,
which automates many important
features like high availability
and patching.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
I will pick Redis for now.
And I'm enabling Memory
Store in this project.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Good.
Now click Create Instance.
Give it a name and
a display name.
For the rest of the fields,
the defaults are fine.
Now click Create.
Now your Redis server
is being initialized.
This server sits in a
virtual private cloud,
so it's not accessible
from the public internet.
So next, we need to
set up a connector so
that your Cloud Run
service can connect
to your virtual private cloud.
To do that, first
pick VPC network
in the navigation sidebar.
Then click serverless
VPC access.
Click Create Connector and give
it the name My VPC Connector.
Under network, pick
Default. Under subnet,
pick custom IP Range.
And go ahead and enter that
suggested 10.8.0.0 in the IP
text box and click Create.
Now head back over
to the Memory Store
and copy the IP address
of the Redis instance
that you just created.
In your deployment shell script,
add Redis host, Redis port,
and VPC connector as
environment variables.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
Now that is done, I will build
and deploy the container.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
Is it working?
MARTIN OMANDER: Let's see.
Let me reload the page here.
Refresh.
Yeah, it's working.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
OK, awesome.
Let's recap what
you have achieved.
By moving your
container to Cloud Run,
you no longer need
to maintain a server.
And your service auto
scales as load increases.
And we have Cloud Run
to thank for this.
Now, Cloud Run is able to
offer these features by not
storing the data in memory.
So by putting the session data
in Redis via memory store,
you won't lose it if the
user's second request hits
a different server than
their first request
or if an app server crashes.
MARTIN OMANDER: I like that.
Have we earned another
tea break, Dina?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: I think so.
MARTIN OMANDER: Thank
you all for watching.
If you have any
questions for Dina or me,
enter them in the
comments below,
and we'll try to answer them.
Also let us know what other
serverless topics we should
bring up in this video series.
Bye for now.
[MUSIC PLAYING]